front of this public lecture uh
organized by the simons institute for
the
theory of computing my name is peter
bartlett i'm the associate director
uh at the the institute um the simon's
institute is a living venue for
uh collaborative research in theoretical
computer science
it brings together top researchers and
the next generation of outstanding young
scholars to explore
deep unsolved problems about the nature
and limits of computation
and about what a computational viewpoint
can reveal in other areas
the institute's been going since 2012
and its core activities revolve around
uh two
semester-long research programs on
specific topics in the foundations of
computing and in
related fields this semester we've been
convening two online programs one on
satisfiability
uh and one on the theoretical
foundations of computer systems
and the institute has a long-standing
tradition of appointing a science
communicator in residence
with the aims of supporting authors
journalists in the areas of computer
science and mathematics
and of helping them connect with the
experts that
are here participating in our in our
programs
also we aim to increase the visibility
of theoretical computer science and
and uh to help educate our participants
about
communicating their work to a broader
audience and
this semester we're delighted to have as
our science communicator in residence
siobhan roberts siobhan is a canadian
author and science journalist she writes
for the new york times quanta and the
new yorker
she's the author of a biography of john
conrad john conway
and she wrote an obituary for the new
york times
when he passed away last year she's
written a biography of donald
coxeta and and she wrote and produced a
documentary about him also
she's won the american mathematical
society and the mathematical association
of america's jpbm
communications award for expository and
popular books
and the mathematical association of
america's euler prize for expanding the
public's view of mathematics
and she's currently writing a biography
of the group theorist and logician
verena
hoover dyson so we're delighted to have
siobhan back as the science communicator
in residence she was here a year ago
um and her talk today is entitled
embracing the uncertainties
welcome shivan thank you very much peter
um it's delightful to be back at the
simons institute even if just remotely
um i know it's going to be a really
productive semester i
already have a number of story ideas on
the go drawing from
the various workshops and boot camps
so to start perhaps i'll give a bit more
background about me
just for some context as a science
journalist
my beat broadly speaking has been
mathematics
and i have written two biographies of
mathematicians
and i should note however that i don't
have any formal training in math or
science i did degrees in history
and journalism so i take a generalist
approach and i
range around quite a bit i've also
written a biography of a wind engineer
and i've covered everything from
neuroscience to paleontology to
cosmology
and in recent years my focus is more and
more on computing
but my subject today is one that cuts
across the
scientific spectrum and that is
uncertainty
scientific uncertainty is something that
i've been exploring for a while now
but of course it gained an immediacy and
urgency last march
when much of my reporting shifted to
focus on covad 19 and epidemiology and
the pandemic
during my talk i'll reflect on that
reporting which is ongoing still to some
extent
so writing as a freelance contributor
for the new york times last year
um my articles about the pandemic were
what's called service journalism
so trying to do a public service and
sharing essential information and
thereby
increasing awareness my first covid
related piece featured a q a with drew
harris
a population health analyst in
philadelphia who is among the first
people to share and unpack this flatten
the
curve infographic my second piece was
also a q a
with the husband and wife team of bill
hanaj and helen jenkins
both epidemiologists in boston and
they'd composed a version of this
cut the transmission diagram with their
kids on the whiteboard in their kitchen
and more recently i did yet another q a
with ian mckay a virologist in brisbane
australia
who created this swiss cheese
infographic emphasizing how multiple
interventions are necessary
to mitigate and contain the coronavirus
so
social distancing masks vaccination no
one intervention suffices on its own
all are necessary and have a cumulative
effect in containing cobit 19.
so these pieces all aim to convey the
relative certainties
some of the information we know to be
true the bottom line being
human behavior has a big effect on the
dynamics of the pandemic
but the broader picture of course
quickly revealed itself to be one of
profound
uncertainty i first wrote about that in
april
last year with my article titled
embracing the uncertainties
back then confirmed global cases of
illness from
coronavirus were approaching 1.5 million
and reported deaths were
into the six figures but there were big
unknowns such as what are the true rates
of infection and mortality
this art accompanied the article it's by
the illustrator steven savage
and at first i wasn't quite sure about
it because it didn't capture what i'd
hoped was at least a somewhat comforting
or reassuring message
but now i do think it was spot on
because here we are a year later still
trying to outrun
many of the same uncertainties and the
toll is massive
confirmed cases worldwide are almost at
115 million
and reported deaths exceed 2.5 million
and there are still uncertainties such
as the emergence of the variants
and whether they will achieve viral
escape or whether vaccines and natural
immunity will still be effective
as i said in the article this type of
uncertainty about facts
numbers and science is called epistemic
uncertainty
it's caused by a lack of knowledge about
the past and the present
or is david spiegelhalter a statistician
at the winton center for risk and
evidence communication at cambridge put
it
epistemic uncertainty is caused by our
ignora our ignorance
science of course is full of epidemic
uncertainty
circling the unknowns inching toward
truth through argument and experiment is
how scientific progress is made
but science is often expected or assumed
to be a monolithic collection
of all the right answers as a result
scientists
and the politicians policymakers and
journalists who depend on them
are reluctant to acknowledge the
inherent uncertainties
worried that candor undermines
credibility
we've seen this again and again
throughout the pandemic especially in
the early stages
spiegelhalter was the main source for my
embracing the uncertainties article
since in googling around i came upon
this article it was
timely on the effects of communicating
uncertainty on public trust in facts and
numbers
it was by a group of researchers at the
wynton center together with
collaborators in math
and social psychology and the question
behind their study asked
what happens when scientists do
acknowledge uncertainty
the paper was published in late march of
last year
but it had been submitted for review in
august of 2019 so the timing was just
fortuitous
the study's motivation as spiegelhalter
explained it
was rooted in quote the accusations of a
post-truth society
and claims that the public had had
enough of experts
this prompted the researchers to
investigate whether trust in
experts was lowered by their openly
admitting uncertainty
about what they know but to the contrary
the study's findings suggested
that being transparent about uncertainty
does not in fact
harm the public's trust in the facts or
in the source
to give you a brief snapshot of the
methodology
using online surveys the study measured
reactions to uncertainty
expressed in statements about various
subjects such as the number of tigers
left in india
the increase in global average surface
temperature between 1880 and 2010
and unemployment figures in the united
kingdom
the survey was replicated in the wild so
to speak with a field study on the bbc
news website
the researchers tested two different
ways of expressing uncertainty
quantitatively with a numerical range or
percentage
versus qualitatively using a word such
as estimated or approximately
and the counter-intuitive results showed
the more precise numerical statements
were more effective
both in conveying uncertainty and in
maintaining trust
there was in fact a minor reduction in
trust but they deemed the effect so
small as to be trivial
so the conclusion as described by one of
the co-authors
was that people can handle the truth
about the level of certainty or
uncertainty
that exists regarding scientific facts
and knowledge
again all this research and analysis had
been conducted in 2018 and 2019
but starting in march of last year the
experiment was replicated in several
countries in the context of the pandemic
with statements about the severity of
covid19
among other questions about trust and
trustworthiness
of government officials and scientists
and as the results confirmed the papers
findings
this is a graph showing the level of
trust in scientists handling of the
pandemic
and this is the level of trust in
information from government
lower but not too too
so as alexandra freeman a co-author and
the executive director of the winton
center told me
quote where there is uncertainty around
kobit 19 scientists shouldn't feel
concerned about communicating this to
the public
in fact it may be important to do so
this group of researchers has been
exploring uncertainty in its many forms
for a while now freeman told me that at
a conference of uncertainty specialists
about two years ago she asked attendees
to write definitions of uncertainty on
post-it notes
and stick them on the wall everyone was
different she said
but her favorite was anything and
everything that can
muck up a decision insert your
descriptor of choice
the march study focused on people's
reactions to epistemic uncertainty
things we don't know about the past and
present but in theory could come to know
through measurement the team since
then has started researching perceptions
of alleatory uncertainty
unknowns about the future due to
randomness indeterminacy
chance or luck most uncertainty is a mix
of epistemic
and alliatory for instance how many more
people
by the end of the pandemic we'll get
kobit 19.
common wisdom from a psychological
perspective is that people do not like
uncertainty
especially about the future and that it
generates a negative response
this is called ambiguity aversion but
from a statistical perspective
the hypothesis is that people have a
positive reaction
and trust information more when the
communicator is being open about the
uncertainties
and this was borne out in the research
for a broader perspective
i consulted with lorraine daston an
historian of science at the max
planck institute for the history of
science in berlin
she's someone i had consulted with
previously on my uncertainty
investigations she found the study's
results heartening
and she pointed out that the public in
turn must be open to considering and
adapting to new evidence
she said we the public must expect
scientific views on the nature of the
virus
and how best to combat it to change as
more evidence comes in
and we must be prepared to change our
conduct accordingly
so that was the scientific core of my
first reporting
on uncertainty but i continued down the
rabbit hole a bit further
in that article i learned for instance
that in the early days of the outbreak
when data was just emerging from china
we were in a state of what's called
deep uncertainty also known as radical
uncertainty
that is a quagmire of unknown unknowns
there were no constraints
sometimes it feels as if we're still
stuck in fairly deep uncertainty
but even last spring spiegelhalter
argued that the uncertainty had been
significantly constrained
he defines statistical science as a
machine to turn the variability that we
see in the world
the unpredictability the enormous amount
of scatter
and randomness that we see around us
into a tool that can quantify our
uncertainty about facts and numbers and
science
similarly mathematical modeling provides
projections
that at once show and evaluate the
uncertainties
but models that we as we've seen are
imperfect and have limitations
models are simplifications of the real
world as the saying goes the map
is not the territory this is reminiscent
of a one paragraph story
by the argentine writer jorge luis
borges written in 1946
on exactitude in science or on rigor in
science depending on the translation
the story is about a map that grows as
large as the territory it was meant to
represent
daston had first put me onto the borges
parable so i went back to her
and asked about its relevance in the
context of the ongoing conversation
around the limits of modeling
she said to quote the parable captures a
failing of a particular kind of model
that is increasingly common in the age
of big data
vast increases in computing power have
made it possible to
fit a past sequence of events to a high
degree of accuracy
the problem with such retrofitted models
is that they're bad at predicting
like the map that duplicates the empire
they cannot be extrapolated to new
territories
nor do they help us navigate the
territory we know because they are
theoryless
no one feature of the past phenomena is
picked out as more significant than any
other
to continue the map analogy a small
creek is reproduced as faithfully as a
mighty river
even though the latter is a far more
consequential consequential feature of
the landscape
so in short the upshot of the borges
story
is that a map which grows as large as
the empire represents
becomes essentially useless and science
without uncertainty
is not only useless but impossible this
is a point that came up
in a conversation i had not too long ago
with the astro
physicist saskia hecker at the
heidelberg institute for theoretical
studies
i spent last term there as a journalist
in residence
hecker mentioned that when she started
studying astrophysics she was shocked to
discover
that sometimes there are very large
uncertainties in measuring stars
the amount of uncertainty and results
pertaining to the age of a star can be
as much as 50 percent
but when she she went on to note that in
what became her area of specialty
that is astro seismology studying the
internal structure of stars
various tools sharpen the measurements
and reduce the uncertainty
for instance the age of a red giant star
her particular subject of interest
can be estimated within about 20 to 30
percent or even 10
in very good cases so that is indeed a
considerable reduction in uncertainty
another researcher at the heidelberg
institute vince
uvlin leads the research group on data
mining and uncertainty quantification
this line of investigation doesn't try
to reduce the uncertainty
but rather accepts it and aims to
compute it in order to derive the impact
on large data sets
oovlein explained that the most obvious
way of understanding uncertainty
is forward propagation given a starting
point what will happen
and with what degree of uncertainty
there is also backward propagation
given a result that shows uncertainty
what is the origin
of the uncertainty one application
that he's been investigating is in the
medical field
for instance given cardiac surgery and a
complexity of variables what is the
corridor of the result
or what is the corridor of the
uncertainty
since uncertainty computation is highly
cpu intensive
hublin works on what he calls hardware
aware computing
that is increasing the accuracy of an
uncertainty prediction
by increasing the compute power for
models using at best the underlying
hardware architecture of supercomputers
and then in the context of the pandemic
a third area of research at the
heidelberg institute
that caught my attention was the
computational statistics group
led by tillman gneiting area of
expertise is forecasting
for instance environmental sciences and
weather and economics and finance
last fall a postdoc in the computational
statistics group johannes bracker
gave a seminar about a relatively new
project that he's coordinating called
the german polish kobit 19 forecast hub
this is a screenshot of the online
platform
the goal of the forecast hub is
basically to map or quantify the
uncertainty
with short-term probabilistic
predictions of covid19 cases and deaths
here the deaths are shown the focus is
on one and two-week forecasts
the outer range is three and four-week
forecasts but they are much less
reliable
and the researchers always like to
emphasize the distinction between
short-term forecasts which attempt to
predict what is going to be observed in
the future
versus longer-term scenario forecasts
which make a what-if
hypothesis statement about the future
for instance
how would the case rates change if
nursing home staff were tested twice a
week instead of once a week
in this graph each color represents a
model by a different modeling team
and the width of the color band
indicates the range of uncertainty
more specifically the aim of the
forecast hub is to improve
uncertainty predictions so again not to
reduce the uncertainty
since given the nature of the pandemic
reducing uncertainty is impossible
as knighting explains to me to quote
it's different with weather
he said with weather we use models to
reduce uncertainty
it's easy to quantify because there is a
clear-cut baseline
based on data from previous years for
example we know it's going to snow every
20th day or every 30th day in winter
on average in heidelberg so by using
weather forecasts we can substantially
reduce
uncertainty but for copay 19 there's no
baseline at all
instead the goal is to make the best
attempt at quantifying the uncertainty
the approach is as follows the
researchers collect various forecasts
done by independent teams
in academia government and industry and
put them together in what's called an
ensemble forecast the ensemble forecast
combines and compares
analyzes and averages all the different
predictions
the various models give differing
forecasts because they use
different data sources and methodologies
and what the researchers have found is
that the ensemble model
tends to do a better job predicting the
uncertainty
it is a better it is better than any
average
it is is better than any individual
forecast on average
as bracker put it one of the major
advantages of the ensemble
is that it is more stable individual
models tend to get thrown off
now and then when something doesn't go
right the ensemble model
in averaging all the results provides
more stability
it is rarely the best model but is often
among the better models and in the long
run
shows good average performance
the german polish forecast hub runs in
close collaboration with the u.s
cobia 19 forecast hub which is led by
nicholas reich's lab at the university
of massachusetts
and whereas the german polish hub
assembles 18 models
the u.s hub is an aggregate of about 75
models
the key purpose of this type of
uncertainty quantification
and probabilistic forecasting is to
allow for the best possible decision
making
but even ensemble forecasts are far from
perfect
gniting told me that the experience has
been quite sobering
because this research demonstrates that
even with state-of-the-art models there
is substantial
uncertainty the pandemic is simply
uncharted territory
but nevertheless he sees value in these
investigations even if only in simply
making clear that any kind of
predictions
and hence policy decisions regarding the
pandemic are incredibly difficult
so that's been my current focus a couple
weeks ago there was a long-awaited paper
posted by this international
collaboration
this is the paper's author list with 70
different um
authors and affiliations which i think
slowed down the editing process quite a
bit
i had to get many approvals um and for
me i think it
it might prove a jumping off point for
an article sort of digging into
um you know the uncertainty and modeling
further
um the advantage of ensemble forecasts
and just sort of trying to further
enlighten our our chronic state of
uncertainty
as nick reich who leads the u.s hub put
it recently in an op-ed in the
washington post
he said the pandemic is shaped by human
behavior so educating people about the
benefits and limitations of forecasts
can help us in a sense fight the
pandemic
my latest published article on covid19
covered a vaccine prioritization study
the study used what's called a coupled
model
modeling both human behavior and disease
dynamics
it was somewhat atypical for an
infectious disease study
because it applied game theory a
mathematical way of modeling how people
make strategic decisions within a group
combining that with more traditional
epidemiological
modeling the real novelty here was
factoring in human behavior
into the modeling with the goal of
greater accuracy in the projections
this was by another husband and wife
team chris bosch at the university of
waterloo
and madur anand at the university of
guelph in canada
and their phd student peter gents
and the prisoner's dilemma is a scenario
of course in which players weigh
cooperation against betrayal often
producing a less than optimal outcome
for the common good
um and when the story was published a
reader wrote in and pointed out that
another game theory framework would also
be relevant
it's called an assurance game or trust
dilemma which describes a conflict
between safety and social cooperation
but as bots described it the pandemic
presents an everyday complexity of such
choices
imagine if every everyone followed
public health recommendations
they wore masks socially distanced
washed their hands followed stay-at-home
orders
he said in that case of course there is
a significantly reduced
risk of infection but there are always
trade-offs
and temptations to defect from the
regimen maths are annoying hand washing
is tedious
sometimes we need a hug in his lectures
when talking about the use of game
theory
in human environment systems modeling
watch likes to invoke
the comparison between the writer and
rand who made a virtue of selfishness
and star trek spock who said the needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
few
researchers argued that using game
theory to model human behavior
injects an extra dose of realism to
epidemiological modeling
they drew on they drew on google data
that revealed who went where when in
ontario from march to november
and this data was used as a proxy in the
game theory model
approximating how stringently people
adhere to social distancing
and other public health advice over time
it captures how people respond to the
ups and downs of daily existence
and how our actions in turn make all the
difference as i heard one epidemiologist
put it
an army of umbrellas won't change the
weather but vaccination can be a
powerful force in defeating the
coronavirus
now the final piece i'll highlight is
one that i published back
in august which ran under the headline
how to think like an epidemiologist
but the working title had been how to
think like a bayesian
which more accurately captures what the
piece was getting at i think
it looked at how bayesian analysis can
be used in
an epidemiological setting to hone the
accuracy of predictions and projections
this piece although published in august
originated way back
in last march when i spoke to bill hanaj
about that
breaking the chain of transmission
infographic he'd made a kind of offhand
remark about given all the
new information coming in daily he was
in a constant state of reminding himself
to
update your priors and that was just a
phrase that caught my attention
and then i saw it mentioned on twitter
here and there and i got googling
and that sent me down the the bayesian
rabbit hole
so as i stated here at the outset of the
piece update your priors refers to the
iterative process
of updating evidence and the gradual
accumulation of knowledge
this is in a sense the heart of bayesian
analysis named after thomas bayes
an 18th century presbyterian minister
who did math on the side
and bayes theorem is a device for
rationally updating your prior beliefs
and uncertainties based on observed
evidence
now i'd say i was aware of bayes
generally speaking
but i definitely needed a bayesian boot
camp of sorts to
to get myself uh up to speed on the
finer details
which i'm still not sure i have the best
grasp of but
i definitely have the gist of it um and
for this the statistician joe blitzstein
at harvard proved an invaluable source
blitz dean delves into the utility of
bayesian analysis in his popular
course statistics 110 which he's given
15 years running with one sabbatical
year in there
and the entire course is available on
youtube
in lecture one for primer he says math
is the logic of certainty
and statistics is the logic of
uncertainty everyone has uncertainty
if you have 100 certainty about
everything there's something wrong with
you
by the end of lecture four he arrives at
bayes theorem
which he says is his favorite theorem
because it is mathematically simple
yet can conceptually powerful
in blitzstein's hands it can be proved
in one line
and he likes to say the theorem
essentially reduces to a fraction
and it expresses the probability p of
some event a
happening given the occurrence of
another event b
he said to quote naively you would think
how much can you get from that
it turns out to have deep consequences
and to be applicable to just about every
field of inquiry
from genetics to political science to
historical studies and beyond
as i found digging around the bayesian
approach is used in analyzing racial
disparities in policing
and in search and rescue operations the
search area narrows as no
new data is added cognitive scientists
ask is the brain bayesian and
philosophers of science posit
that science as a whole is a bayesian
process as is common sense
bayes theorem is also frequently used to
assess the accuracy of diagnostic tests
factoring in the sensitivity and
specificity of the tests and this is a
subject that was discussed
quite a bit at the beginning of the
pandemic how accurate were the covet
tests how likely were false positives
and false negatives
and what were the implications and if
you're interested in doing a deep dive
in this
i'd recommend blitzstein's animated
explainer titled bayesville
on youtube which is both charming and
informative
so the scientific core of my bayesian
article
was a study exploring a somewhat novel
use of bayesian analysis
in epidemiological modeling by two
researchers at stanford susan holmes and
her then phd student claire donnett
donna has since received her phd and
she's now at chicago
their motivation came by observing
research in march
about how the pandemic might evolve they
noticed that classic epidemiological
models
tended to used fixed parameters or
constants
for the reproduction number say a
reproduction number of two
the reproduction number being the
average number of secondary cases
generated per infectious case but in
reality of course the reproduction
number is not a constant
it depends on random uncertain factors
viral loads and susceptibility
behavior and social networks culture
socioeconomic class weather
air conditioning and many other unknowns
with a bayesian perspective
they explained the uncertainty is
encoded into randomness
donna and holmes began by supposing that
the reproductive number had various
distributions
the priors then they modeled the
uncertainty
using a random variable that fluctuates
taking on a range of values
as small as 0.6 and as large as 3.5
in something of a nesting process the
random variable itself has parameters
that fluctuate randomly
and those parameters too have random
parameters or hyperparameters
and so on the effects accumulate into a
bayesian hierarchy
holmes calls it turtles all the way down
and she explained that the
up and down random fluctuations multiply
like compound
interest as a result the study found
that using random variables
for reproductive numbers more
realistically predicts
the risky tail events the rarer but more
significant super spreaders
i spoke to a number of researchers about
this somewhat atypical approach
to covid19 research and modeling
to get a survey of opinions and they
agreed it was valuable
natalie dean a biostatistician at the
university of florida
said we should be less focused on
finding the single truth
and more focused on establishing a
reasonable range recognizing that
the true value may vary across
populations bayesian analysis allows us
to include this variability
in a clear way and then propagate this
uncertainty
through the model humans on their own
however
without a bayesian model for a compass
are notoriously bad at fathoming
individual risk
but it is a perspective that one can
cultivate
for mark lipsich an infectious disease
epidemiologist at harvard
bayesian reasoning comes awfully close
to what he calls his
working definition of rationality
he said as we learn more our beliefs
should change
one extreme is to decide what you think
and be impervious to new information
another extreme is to over privilege the
last thing you learned
in rough terms bayesian reasoning is a
principled way to integrate
what you previously thought with what
you have learned and come to a
conclusion that incorporates them both
giving them appropriate weights
but even with evidence revising beliefs
isn't easy
not even for scientists and experts
we've seen this with the world health
organization
with its advice about masks for instance
when we don't update problems arise
returning to spiegelhalter who's always
good value
he said you can interpret confirmation
bias and so many ways in which we react
poorly
by being too slow to revise our beliefs
but he also noted optimistically that
various techniques
compensate for bayesian shortcomings
he's particularly fond of a general
approach called
cromwell's law and i'll give
spiegelhalter the last word
and end with a paraphrasing of his
retelling of cromwell's law it goes like
this
in 1650 oliver cromwell lord protector
of the commonwealth of england
wrote in a letter to the church of
scotland i beseech you
in the bowels of christ think it
possible you may be mistaken
in the bayesian world spiegelhaltzer
said cromwell's law means you should
always keep
a bit back with a little bit of
probability a tiny little bit
for the fact that you may be wrong then
if new evidence comes along that totally
contradicts your main prior belief
you can quickly ditch what you thought
before and lurch over to that new way of
thinking
in other words spiegelhalter said keep
an open mind
that's a very powerful idea and it
doesn't have to
be done technically or formally it can
just be in the back of your mind as an
idea
call it modeling humility he said you
may be wrong
and with that i will end and open it up
to questions if there are any
fantastic thanks very much uh
so uh people can use the q a feature
uh or i would just speak up if
um in here as a as a panelist um
um let let me start siobhan the
um uh the spiegel halter study that you
presented at the start about the impact
on trust
of uh communicating uncertainty
showed that it helps to to be
quantitative
i guess um you know i'm curious about
that it seems like there
as you pointed out there are lots of
different kinds of uncertainty you know
if you have
if you have well modeled randomness then
it's very easy to quantify that and
that's the sort of thing that i imagine
would
would definitely increase trust if you
realize you know what the error bars are
for for something that's well modeled
but this other sort of um you know uh
unmodeled uh uncertainty about our
models um
you know that's the experts that are
disagreeing or even worse and
you know uncertainty our models there
are diagnostics that demonstrate our
models aren't
right but we don't have the right ones
uh you know it feels like these are
different kinds of uncertainty that and
communicating them could have a very
different impact about
yeah i mean i think in my discussions
with
um rainey daston the overall um
conclusion that that she has you know
come to and is is kind of concerned
about is that the public has a
um you know a slightly skewed idea of
what science
broadly speaking is all about and just
this notion that
things should be certain and it's it's a
binary true and false and
um you know so yeah there's there's
definitely
spectrum of uncertainty and some results
are more reliable than others and
and so it's it's it's kind of this
russian doll nesting effect of
uncertainty and where do you end and so
we're kind of swimming in it
um but i guess that's the the broader
point is that we need to be more
comfortable with with uncertainty and
you know and
and also that goes along with sort of
encouraging critical thinking and you
know to just constantly be in kind of a
mode of
of gauging what the uncertainty is and
how reliable
um spiegel halter actually i followed up
with him and and asked him
what the latest was and they published
another um
uh paper just about five rules for
evidence communication
and and and talking about you know um
not only disclosing uncertainties but
the idea of informing not persuading
offering balance not false balance so
there's various tools that
you know assuming good good will on the
part of
the scientists and that they're they're
doing
you know results that that have
integrity that you know i think are ways
that would help the public
come to grips with uncertainty
so i guess i was asking about the
original study
and what was the nature of the
uncertainty there you know was it was it
low in the the hierarchical bayesian
model or was it you know
uncertainties about the experts
disagreeing in what what's the right way
to model a phenomenon
in terms of the types of uncertainty
they were they were studying
yeah and that and that you know this
result about um
not having much of an impact on trust
you know was that
what was the nature of the uncertainty
in that in that study
um well they were looking at um i mean
if i remember
correctly it wasn't it wasn't too
technical i mean they were just
testing statements about things like
tigers in england and
you know the unemployment rate and and
so
giving people statements that that
either included a numerical
quantitative descriptor versus a word a
word like approximately and then they
just
you know surveyed people you know which
statement do you think is more accurate
which person seems more reliable um so
yeah it wasn't
you know getting into the the details of
bayesian hierarchy is a totally other
ball of wax for sure and i don't i don't
think they were probing those levels of
yeah but it sounds like literacy yeah
what you called alia tree um
yes right right all right great
any other questions sure uh
i know in terms of covid modeling there
have been a variety of models over time
initially
there were epidemiological models like
the oxford model that were predicting
uh very quickly uh
you know millions of deaths uh there was
the institute for health metrics model
which was a model that you
that used past curves and couldn't
possibly
produce metrics of uncertainty which
were actually
at least initially convinced the trump
administration to do something
though they had problems and how they
were going down so then hugely
criticized
and then in the fall while all the other
models
epidemiological models were suggesting
that things would stay down if you
looked at
there's bubbles of the sort that you saw
all the others were predicting that
things would be
going down if you look even early in
october
and even things like uh goo's model
at that point um they were predicting
a very substantial increase in the fall
with their curve fitting models where
you couldn't express uncertainty
and so i'm just interested in you know
these uncertainties are with with public
and also
with you know decision makers in
positions of a
uh authority you have to
change it and just what you've seen sort
of in the balance of that i mean i don't
have any particular
uh thing to you know direction to push
you in
asking the question but just generally
what's your reaction to that
and uncertainty um
yeah i mean i guess it's along the same
lines that it's it's um
definitely confusing and it makes it
sort of seem like it's a futile effort
to really
hone in on any specifics but i think you
know cumulatively and iteratively i
think
just to i think to continue to take it
in and to be
um you know try and synthesize in a
critical
way i mean i think that's the only
strategy i don't know what what else we
can
what else we can do in this situation i
mean it's
in the ensemble um team i mean that's
kind of an interesting
approach and that they it you know by
averaging maybe
it kind of you know shades out some of
the the spikes
um and i'm i'm kind of looking at that
right now in goo's work but
yeah i'm not i'm keen to think hear what
anybody else might think about that i
think it's
you know it is what it is and we we just
have to sort of
adjust our lens broadly speaking is the
only way to
to deal with it i think
so do you think there's any difference
in in sort of how
how this communication should go for the
general
public or do you see their versus you
know
makers or do you uh is
i don't i don't know whether any yeah
yeah i mean i think decision
decision makers and policymakers should
be able to um
you know look at a greater more granular
set of facts and results and and perhaps
try to
you know make more refined decisions
based on that but as connecting said
you know um it's it's kind of an
impossible task for them
as well i mean you sort of you you make
your
best bet and cross your fingers and you
hope that
you're within the realms of of reality
um i guess it's you know it's a very
there's no baseline so just have to do
the best we can i guess
that's right that's not very satisfying
but
it's fine
so i'd be interested to hear your
thoughts on where
the biggest sources of public
misunderstanding of science
come from uh do you think it's something
scientists are doing wrong is it
journalists is it the education system
is it politicians
yeah i mean i think it has to go back to
to some degree education
um you know especially with mathematics
there's the kind of knee-jerk phobia of
of math and
you know there are many in terms of the
media there's many outlets that are
doing
[Music]
quite a good job in terms of trying to
present the complexities and distill
them down
um but it's hard to control the quality
of
coverage when you have so many so many
different outlets and it's
on social media and people essentially
just you know have time to read the
the headlines you know they're not
necessarily um
taking in the entire article and even in
i've found that even in
some of the outlets that are that are
doing the deep reporting and
really taking time to explain and try
and unpack
things that that still the headline will
will be a bit
sensationalist and and won't necessarily
get at the content the substance of the
article and
and sometimes you see that the you know
there's there's mild outrage at the
headlines and
and you go back the next day and the
headline has changed and
and so i think that's you know with with
covet i think that's something that
editors are
are um gradually realizing is that you
know
you have to be slightly more pragmatic
and
and straightforward in in crafting the
headlines
when when you're writing about copin 19
and the pandemic
um but it's it's it's been interesting
to see
you know there's been debates about
science journalists who are
essentially covering pre-preprints so
before
an article even makes it to the the
pre-print server
[Music]
a journalist will get access to it and
you know do rigorous reporting and
and consult with 20 different um
scientists and get their views on it and
and
and publish it and and that gets
criticism and pushback
um but they're kind of ahead of the
head of the curve and and science or
journalism
as they described it you know it has its
own motivations and its own
um mechanisms and and processes and it's
it's not to necessarily wait
for scientific papers to be um reviewed
and published formally especially in the
middle of a pandemic
so i mean i think everybody's grappling
with a changing
state of play and and trying to you know
do their job with integrity and um you
know trying to get the best
information as possible out there um
but you know i think in terms of i've
kind of meandered off
from your question but um i think just
the more we can get the public engaged
in
in in science and and how it
obviously infiltrates our our life day
to day um
in an odd way i think that the pandemic
has forced that and maybe it's something
that will
then carry over into uh climate change
coverage and
and other areas and i think that would
be a positive for sure
so wonderful one of the things i have in
mind is
um the way schools teach science
is um okay you go and do an experiment
and you should get the right answer and
if you don't get the right answer then
you
you don't get the grades and it it
doesn't seem to be
late on saying until late on in the
university degree where you're suddenly
taught to
think about the uncertainties think
about the sources of errors
do you think there's a way to better
communicate thinking about uncertainty
to
for example primary or secondary school
education
yeah i mean it just takes it you know it
really comes down to the
the teachers and whether they have the
the attention
um you know the intention the attention
in terms of energy
the support and the resources um
to i guess adjust the curriculum in in
those
subtle ways that you know take the time
and explore those subjects
similarly with mathematics you know you
you do the drills and
um you know i loved the drills in math
and as soon as it got
uh hard it was you know it quickly
became my worst subject and although i
continued along with it you know the
idea was
you know the feeling was well i'm
horrible at it this is you know this is
bad but
in fact that's when math starts to get
interesting you know you're when you're
when you're feeling uncomfortable that's
essentially what mathematics is all
about
um and so to make things like that clear
to students definitely at a at
an early age it should shift their
perspective of what science and math are
all about
peter sarnak said when i was writing the
the conway book
um you know his his steady state is is
one of frustration
um and you really have to just be
comfortable being frustrated and
um and that's that's the
mathematical research process which i
found fascinating
um it's definitely something i
identified with from my limited
experience with mathematics
thank you and
maria had a question
yes thank you
don't you think that
perhaps the communication could be
improved by being more
multi-disciplinary for example
i noticed that um during this pandemic
the experts who have been mostly
asked to come forward with the
information
have been almost invaluably medical
doctors
or at most mathematicians and
statisticians
whereas i think that also
historians computer scientists
um scientists
doing ecology should be involved
because all these facets contribute
to understand the picture the picture
for example
if you ask a historian they could point
out that epidemics always
existed in human history and so maybe
this is
less new than people
might think up front um
if you uh if uh scientists
who studied the environment were asked
they could point
out that most likely
this illness is its own oasis
and that is evaluates that mutated
from a non-human species to the human
species
and this has happened before it happened
with
hiv it happened with the first sars
and i mean
for example people connect the happening
of these mutations and they apparent
higher frequency if it is true i'm not
an expert in that area
in the latest years with the degradation
of the environment
so i think that a more
multi-disciplinary approach
could help could help the public
tolerate and understand this
situation of not knowing many things
thank you yeah i thoroughly agree and i
think i think we have seen that
to some extent and and and to some
extent that's
what i've tried to do in my coverage i
haven't so much covered results of
studies but i've been i've been covering
um novel approaches so um
i mean statisticians are are well within
the realm of modeling and um but you
know the the
the study done by uh chris bach and
madurai nand you know they're
she's an ecologist and a poet he's a a
mathematical biologist
um but you know so they're they're
bringing a different um
perspective um and and you know in
bringing
uh rainey dowston in with the historical
perspective um there was definitely more
of her insight that i could have
included in the piece but
you know there wasn't there wasn't room
but and i think you do see
people in in a variety of disciplines um
contributing
sometimes it's more with um op-ed pieces
um but i think i think it has been
reasonably
kind of well-rounded and in that um
respect you know maybe in in the latter
months
you know the latter half of last year
when people started to kind of pull back
and
and look for the the broader
perspectives that could be more
informative
but i think it's a very good point
definitely
all right thanks very much um so so join
me in thanking siobhan for a
really great talk that was really
fascinating you've given us a lot to
think about
thank you glad you enjoyed it
my pleasure